Yes, AI is ruining your writing, but not
for the reason you think.
I'm an English professor, and for the
past 10 years, I've been helping people
share their knowledge and expertise
through clear, valuable writing. And as
I've been watching this great AI writing
debate play out, I've got to say, I
think it misses something fundamental.
So, in today's video, I want to go over
the two AI writing workflows to show you
what's wrong with incorporating AI at
any stage of your writing process. And I
promise you, this is not going to
devolve into one of these cranky rants
about how AI is corrupting the art form,
or how my taste is better than yours.
That's where I think a lot of this AI
debate happens, and that's at the wrong
level. It's at the surface level. So,
instead, I want to go one step deeper to
not only show you what's wrong with
incorporating AI into your non-fiction
writing, but also show you how to fix it
so that you can show up as your best
authentic self with your audience and
deliver real value to them.
And so, what do I mean when I say this
debate is happening at the wrong level?
Well, imagine this.
The spirit that you bring to your
writing should really be like the spirit
that you would bring to a first date.
You can't show up to a first date, you
know, unshowered and monosyllabic and
staring down at your phone. Not if you
want a second date, that is.
And if you do show up to a first date
with the spirit of someone who really
doesn't want to be there, then that's
going to permeate through every surface
level feature of that date. It's going
to show up in the way that you present
yourself. It's going to show up in your
language choices. And no amount of
editing at that surface level could
rehabilitate that date and lead to a
second one. That is, if you take
somebody with the spirit of someone who
really doesn't want to be there, and you
dress them up in a nice shirt, or you
put some cologne on, or you kind of
coach them maybe with an earpiece
telling them what to say, it really
doesn't matter. The other person is
going to sense that inauthenticity.
They're going to be saying, "Why are you
here? What do What do you want? Why are
I thought we were here to meet each
other, to communicate with each other?"
All of this AI debate is so focused on
that surface level. It's saying, "Don't
use this sentence structure. Don't
repeat this word. Avoid the M dash."
Right? Like any of that is really going
to make a difference.
Like a first date, writing is about
communication. And communication
doesn't isn't a matter of just the words
that we choose. It's a matter of the way
that we show up for that other person.
It's a meeting of the minds. And in
communication, all the language choices
that we make are downstream
of the way that we choose to relate to
that person. You might notice that in
conversation, you're never thinking
about the words that you're going to
choose. You're never planning what
sentence am I going to say next. They
just kind of fall out of you in the
course of that discussion. Now, of
course, there are some obvious
differences between speaking to somebody
in conversation and writing. Of course,
you know, when you're speaking, you're
in the same room together, you're
looking at each other, and with writing,
you're separated by space and time. But
there's still that fundamental upstream
quality of relating to somebody and
intending to communicate with somebody
that gets lost in both of these AI
workflows. So, what are the workflows?
Well, the first workflow that you see in
AI writing are people who take AI
outputs and then try to dress them up as
their own. So, you might go to your AI
and say, "Give me three points about
whatever the topic is." And it'll give
you a certain output, and then the idea
is that you can take that output and
kind of make it your own. Move some
sentences around and do your own
stylistic edits, and that's supposed to
make things all right. And that
workflow, I think, is the source of so
much of the inauthenticity
that readers are complaining about with
nonfiction writing these days. Now, the
crude way to put this is to say that
when you take AI outputs and then try to
dress them up as your own, you're kind
of polishing a turd. But, it's actually
worse than that because at least with a
turd, you would have some substance.
The outputs of AI, by contrast, are not
even as substantive as a turd because
it's not an idea. If you know a little
bit about how AI works, it's just a
pattern recognition machine. It's taking
words, converting them to numbers,
running probability algorithms, and then
converting those tokens back into words.
It's a parlor trick. It's not an idea.
And the thing about communicative
writing and just communication in
general is that whenever we're talking
to somebody, we have a vision.
So, you have a vision. In fact, I'm kind
of doing it in this video. So, if you've
been watching this channel for a while,
you've seen different styles of videos
that I've made, but this one is off the
cuff. I I don't have a script. I don't
have notes. I'm speaking to you as I
would if we met for coffee.
And the reason I'm doing this is to
demonstrate the point that when you have
something to say, it's almost as though
you've seen something.
The Consider the I'm I'm I'm thinking
here of an idea almost as a vision. Like
you've seen something. You know that
something is true. And so you then
relate to When you want to share that
vision with somebody else, you don't
plan out your sentences in advance. You
don't have to because you have the
vision in mind and you're looking at the
other person in front of you and the
words fall out of you in the course of
describing that vision. Now, the same
thing happens with quality writing. You
have a vision. You You know something to
be true and then you orient yourself
properly to the person who you're
writing to and the language just falls
out of you.
Now,
by contrast, if you are taking AI
outputs and then just trying to gussy
them up with your own stylistic
preferences, you're not beginning with
that spirit. You don't have a vision
that you're actually trying to
articulate. You're just moving words
around in this kind of parlor trick. And
that's why AI writing always rings
hollow. There's nothing to it. It's not
even a turd because it's not an idea.
It's like you have an object and you're
sanding the edges of it, but the object
itself is hollow. So if you take AI
outputs and then try to pass them off as
your own, you're not writing well
because you're not actually
communicating. No thought was had, no
vision was seen, and so although words
are coming out of your mouth or in the
case of writing on the page, they're not
indexing anything real inside of you,
and so it's not authentic communication,
and your reader sense that immediately.
But I really don't think that point is
quite so controversial within the great
AI writing debate. I'm sure many of you
would agree that yes, it's wrong or at
least inauthentic for writers to take an
AI output and then try to pass it off as
their own just by changing the style or
sentence structure or paragraph
organization. We all hate that. But,
there is a second AI workflow that I
think is just as pernicious.
And that workflow is the following.
You take a pile of notes, messy
disorganized notes. Maybe you do some
free writing, maybe you even do a voice
note, and you just kind of ramble into
your phone about the topic for 5 or 10
minutes, and then you hand it off to AI
and you ask it to clean it up.
Now, if you think that's a legitimate
way to go about writing, if you think
that it's perfectly fine to hand off
that version of AI writing to your
readers, then I think there is something
fundamental about writing that you don't
understand. If you think that's true,
then you think that writing style is an
independent variable on top of
substance. You have the substance in
your messy notes, in your free
associated of you know, voice
transcript. That's That's your idea. And
then you are just using AI to enhance
the style. It's as though you're
imagining writing style to be like a
coat of paint that you can put over a
messy substance. But, to show you why
that's wrong and what happens when you
do it that way, let me tell you a little
story about when I moved to South Korea
12 or maybe 14 years ago now. I've lost
count. Uh this was before the advent of
food delivery apps. And so, whenever I
wanted to get Korean chicken delivered
to my house, I had a problem, which is
that I would have to call the the
chicken restaurant and give them my
order over the phone. But, at that time,
my Korean level wasn't I wasn't
competent enough to do this. I I didn't
know how to handle that kind of an
order. And so, what I did was I
memorized the sounds that I would have
to make in order to make this order. I
would call them up and I would just make
the following sounds. "Go shoo ba sa sak
sun sal bae dal ya chuseyo."
I barely knew what that meant, but I
practiced the sounds and once a week I
would call my local chicken shop and I
would make those sounds and if I pulled
it off, 40 minutes later chicken would
arrive at my door.
But, sometimes there was a problem with
that and that is whenever the owner had
some clarifying question that they
needed to ask me. Maybe they were out of
that chicken or maybe they just wanted
to confirm my address and I wouldn't
know what they were saying back to me.
And so, I would panic and hang up the
phone and I don't know, maybe I would
try again later or just walk to the
store myself. But, I think that's a
pretty good model of thinking about this
version of the AI writing workflow.
Because, when you are handing off a mess
of notes to AI and then asking it to
clean it up, what you get is the same
kind of fluency without communication.
When I called up the chicken restaurant,
I sounded slick. I actually had the
phonemes down pretty good. I I had the
first language program that I ever did
in Korean was one that was based on
listen and repeat. And so, I really
worked out the phonemes and I think
whenever I do speak, I can sound quite
fluent. However, I didn't have a deeper
understanding of the language that would
allow me to communicate if anything came
up. And so, once again, my the spirit
that I brought to that exchange was not
one of communication. If the owner of
the chicken restaurant spoke back to me,
I couldn't elaborate. I couldn't
continue because I wasn't really there
to communicate. I was directing an
order. And I think this is why so much
AI writing is making people sound
polished but hollow. They haven't done
the work at the substance level to merit
the kind of smooth, possible, plausible
prose that comes out of the AI level.
And they're not really two variables.
You can't have smooth, polished prose if
you haven't clarified the ideas at the
substance level. In fact, they're
they're not even separate levels.
They're not independent of each other.
And so, as you change one level, you
distort the other. And you actually see
this really clearly if you've ever
played with AI image generators. So, try
this yourself. Take an image of yourself
and then have AI reproduce exactly that
image of you, but maybe from a different
angle. What But tell it to preserve all
the features. Make it look exactly the
same as you.
What you'll find is that there's always
a distortion of the original. The output
that it gives you is plausible. It
shares many of the same
features that you gave it in that
initial input, but there's always
something quite off. Why is that?
Well, it's because in this in this image
generation model, it has not seen you
3D. It hasn't seen you from different
perspectives over time. So, it doesn't
know All it knows is the input that
you've given it. So, it'll manipulate
those inputs, but there's always some
distortion. And the same thing happens
with your writing.
Whenever you give AI a mess of your
thoughts and then ask it to improve
those thoughts, it's never going to
reproduce that thought because it never
had that thought. All it had was the
words that you gave it. And so, it's
seeing your thought from a very limited,
like, two-dimensional view. It hasn't
considered your thought from another
It's not even thoughts, it's just words.
It's a parlor trick.
So, in the same way that with these AI
images, it always comes out distorted.
Similarly, with your writing, it is not
actually seeing the vision you had, the
vision that you bring to communication.
It It's not actually had that vision.
It's not had the idea. It's only had the
words that you used to index that idea.
So, it's a very limited purview on the
image that you're trying to communicate.
And so, the output is always going to be
distorted and limited. Good writing is a
window onto the world. You're the
writer. You've seen something in the
world, and now, through your writing,
you are curating a window and a frame
around that. And you're asking the
reader to, "Please, look. Look at this
thing that I've seen so that you can see
it, too."
But when you take your ideas, and you
ask AI to just spruce them up, what
you're doing is you're having AI create
that window. Now, the AI has not seen
what you've seen in the world. It only
sees the words that you use to index
that vision. And so, the window that it
creates for your reader is always going
to be distorted. It's like a funhouse
mirror, rather than a clear window, a
clear windowpane onto the world. Now, to
this, you might say, "Well, fine, but we
can still preserve AI writing. All we
need to do is give it more context. We
need to have better prompts. We need to
give it more context about the intended
audience. We need to give it more
context about the vision that we're
trying to communicate.
And I I about that I would say two
things. So, one
uh you might have heard of Laplace's
demon. In case you haven't, this is a
problem from physics, which basically
says that if you know to a perfect
mathematical certainty the current
position of every atom in the universe,
then you would be able to predict
history because everything would be
determined by the laws of physics. And
so,
on the one hand, I want to say, "Well,
you can't give your AI perfect context
because you'll never be able to provide
it enough context to perfectly match the
rhetorical situation of your text." But
then a second point I want to say is
that like if you're going to bother, if
you're going to go through all this
effort to try to give your AI all this
context and and and everything that it
needs in order to produce plausible
prose,
why don't you just do it yourself?
Because at this point, you are you're
actually
showing up in a real communication
event. You're just oriented to the wrong
person. It's as though you're
communicating with your AI.
Like at this point of the debate
where you're still trying to preserve
everything about your AI, you're trying
to say, "Okay, well, my AI is just it
has this kind of mind and if I just give
it this kind of context, then it'll
produce the kind of language that I
want." But to that I would say, "Why
don't you just turn away from your AI
and turn to your reader?" It's a lot
easier and it's a lot more fulfilling
because that's all readers are looking
for. They're not looking for flashy
prose or anything like that. They're
looking for a meeting of the minds,
meaningful communication, somebody
showing up with a clear vision of
something in the world that they've seen
as true and that they want to share with
somebody. And somebody who's taken the
time to arrange their text in a way that
will make sense to them.
I think all of this comes down to
spirit. The spirit that you bring to
your writing. And if you are trying to
outsource any stage of your own writing
process to AI, then I think you've
corrupted that spirit. Now, don't get me
wrong. I use AI for all kinds of things.
Just not communicative writing. One of
the great functions of AI that I like to
use is incorporating it into my second
brain. I basically use AI as a
navigation layer to help me sort through
all the notes that I compile. And so if
you want to learn my system for how I
incorporated AI into my Obsidian second
brain, then you can check out this video
right here because it's going to give
you a step-by-step tutorial about how to
actually use AI in your writing. So be
sure to go check it out.